[Musique]
le jeudi après midi on joue au bridge à
la salle sérénité de grand mère à tous
levés enchères la compétition est féroce
mais denis bouvette est un vrai stratège
aux cartes comme en politique c'est moi
qui ai participé avec les 24 délégués de
comté de saint maurice à faire hennir
monsieur couillard il a misé sur
philippe couillard durant la dernière
course à la direction
puis a été l'architecte de la victoire
des libéraux dans la circonscription de
saint maurice en 2014
mais il a abandonné la partie en 2016
son chef selon lui ne jouait pas les
bonnes cartes
je pense qu'on en oublie un petit peu
le monde le vraiment les pauvres les
années le parti libéral avait gagné les
cinq sièges de la région en 2014
il a tout perdu le 1er octobre pour tous
rue à la dernière année avec beaucoup
d'argent et là on s'est mis à dépenser
et je pense qu'il le public mal réagi à
saillon dit on se comprend on s'est
serré la ceinture pendant trois ans
qu'il avoue garrocher l'argent un peu
partout
yamoussoukro your savait pas comment les
gens dépensent pour manger chaque
semaine oui à 75 là on voyait qu'il
était déconnecté il continuera d'appuyer
le parti libéral mais la prochaine
partie se jouera sans lui
[Musique]
diane bergeron préfère pour sa part les
mots croisés au jeu de cartes
une activité qui requiert tout autant de
finesse aujourd'hui les gens aiment seul
changement m l'instantané m le renouveau
organisatrice en chef lors du dernier
scrutin elle s'est vite rendu compte que
le message du parti ne correspondait pas
à la réalité du terrain en mauricie les
autres en réalité i see you put et puis
les mégots usine qui fait une cohésion
tout est en train de changer au tout
faux tout se restructurer mais à clé de
lula monde perdu une génération les
30-40 sont allés faire leur carrière à
l'extérieur et mille pèlerins lui n'a
pas l'intention de faire carrière à
l'extérieur
il étudie la comptabilité au cégep et
compte bien rester en mauricie oui c'est
démotivant sur le coup mais par la suite
on peut voir que faut se relever de ce
sommet comprendra souci ils ne se
laissent pas trop découragé par la
dernière défaite mais souhaite que son
parti répondent mieux aux besoins des
régions l'économie le transport puis le
dollar n'en durable ils misent sur le
prochain chef sera de leadership fort
jeu qu'on a le choix entre plusieurs
options
je vends laquelle nous plaît le plus
laquelle qu'il pleut ce tour 9 à
l'avenue véritable course de véritables
débats ils le souhaitent tous
nous apprennent leurs courses absolument
avec 2000 personnes dans salle qui est
lire le nouveau chef alain enfaux frère
ça c'est à dire les vraies affaires
positionné bon pour une fois il n'est
pas capable de faire quelque chose non
non non faut le prendre le temps de ça c
est du bon côté c'est quoi oui on a fait
des bons coups on a fait des mauvais
coups c'est qu'est ce qu'on veut pour
l'avenir on espère un véritable brassage
des cartes dans l'espoir de jouer la
bonne en 2022 ici hugo lavallée radio
canada shawinigan